>> Bret: GREG PALKOT,
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL HERE.
ERIC TALMAGE IS THE BUREAU CHIEF
FOR THE ASSOCIATED PRESS JEFF
WORLD AS A DEPUTY U.S. POLITICAL
EDITOR FOR THE DAILY MAIL.
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN FOR BEING
HERE.
FIRST OF ALL THERE IS A RARE
ELEMENT THAT THE NORTH KOREANS
CAME OUT AND HOLD A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
CLEARLY THEY WANTED TO BUT THEIR
POINT OF YOU OUT THERE.
YOUR SENSE OF WHERE THINGS ARE
AFTER THE SUMMIT FELL APART?
>> I THINK THE NORTH KOREAN SIDE
WAS CLEARLY SURPRISED BY THE
OUTCOME.
I THINK THEY ARE DISAPPOINTED
THEY WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GOT THEIR POSITION ACROSS.
THEY TOOK AN ISSUE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CLAIM THAT
THEY WANTED ALL SANCTIONS
REMOVED.
ALTHOUGH THEY PRETTY MUCH
ADMITTED THAT THEY ARE LOOKING
FOR ALL THE SANCTIONS TO
REMOVED.
>> Bret: WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE SANCTIONS, FIVE OF THE 11.
IT IS ESSENTIALLY THE MEAT OF
THE SANCTIONS WOULD BE TAKEN
OUT.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
THE NORTH KOREANS CAME OUT WITH
A REALLY BIG ASK.
IT IS NOT SURPRISING THAT THAT
DIDN'T WORK OUT.
WE SHOULD KEEP IN MIND THAT THEY
ALSO --
HE ALSO VOWED TO MAKE AUDITORIUM
ON MISSILE LAUNCHES AND THAT IS
A BIG DEAL.
WE DON'T NEED
TO GO BACK RIGHT INTO CRISIS
MODE.
WE CAN CONTINUE TALKS AND I
THINK THE DOOR WAS LEFT OPEN FOR
THAT.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT WILL BE
ON THE SEAN HANNITY SHOW TONIGHT
AND WEAVE A PIECE OF THAT
TALKING ABOUT HIS
REACTION TO THIS DEAL.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THEY WANTED TO DENUCLEARIZE
IN CERTAIN AREAS AND I WANTED
EVERYTHING.
THE SANCTIONS ARE THERE BUT I
DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE UP THE
SANCTIONS UNLESS WE HAD A REAL
PROGRAM.
THEY ARE NOT READY FOR THAT AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT FULLY.
I REALLY DO.
THEY SPEND A LOT OF TIME
BUILDING THAT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THE WORLD HAS TO BE HAPPY.
I WANTED THEM TO T   DENUCLEARIZ
I WANTED THEM TO T   DENUCLEARI.
>> Bret: THE LOWER LEVEL
OFFICIALS GO AND THEY DO ALL OF
THE GROUNDWORK OF THE LEADERS
COME IN AND KIND OF PULLED A
RABBIT OUT OF THE HAT.
THIS TIME IT IS THE TWO LEADERS
RELATING TO MIKE TO ANY
NEGOTIATING.
>> ABSOLUTELY AND THERE
IS A REASON FOR THAT.
IT'S LESS LIKELY A SITUATION
WHERE YOU FLY 1,000 MILES AND
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING PHYSICAL TO
SHOW FOR IT.
KIM JONG IS NOT THE LEADER OF
EVERY COUNTRY OF THE WORLD, BUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP INVESTED A LOT
IN HIS PERSONAL DIPLOMACY.
>> Bret: HE WALK AWAY.
IT DOES NOT GIVE HIM MORE
STREET CRED IN THE REGION OR
BACK BACK HOME?
>> THE NORTH KOREANS WATCH VERY
CLOSELY AND PEOPLE WHO KNOW HIM
KNOW THAT THIS IS A CLASSIC
NEGOTIATING TACTIC FOR HIM.
IF HE IS UNWILLING TO TAKE THEIR
INITIAL ASKING WALK AWAY, I
THINK THEY KNOW THAT THAT IS
WHAT IS GOING ON.
I THINK TRUMP AND MIKE POMPEO
KNOW THE NORTH KOREANS ARE
TRYING TO MAKE A BED.
>> Bret: DO THINK THE
NORTH KOREANS WILL COME BACK AND
SAY, LET'S TALK AGAIN?
>> DEFINITELY.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS OVER.
NORTH KOREANS LIKE TO COME OUT
HARD IN NEGOTIATIONS LIKE THIS,
IT IS NOT THAT SURPRISING.
I'M SURPRISED THAT BOTH SIDES
ARE MORE AWARE.
THIS WILL CONTINUE.
>> Bret: I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT REPORTING.
HOW DIFFICULT IS THAT?
THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY WATCHING YOU.
YOU ARE FILING, THAT HAS TO BE
CHALLENGING?
>> IT IS A VERY CHALLENGING JOB.
WE HAVE SURPRISING ABILITY TO
GET AROUND AND SEE THINGS.
ACCESS HAS BEEN VERY HARD.
I'M THE ONLY AMERICAN JOURNALIST
WAS REGULARLY COMING IN AND IT
IS DIFFICULT BEING HERE.
>> Bret: THAT IS INTERESTING.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
POLITICS VERY QUICKLY.
HERE'S FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN TALKING ABOUT THE FALLOUT
FROM ALL OF THIS.
>> YOU CANNOT THINK OF ANYONE
WHO HAS THROWN THEIR ARMS AROUND
OR CHOSEN THE WORD OF DICTATOR
AND THUGS OVER EVEN OUR OWN
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
STANDING BEFORE THE WORLD AND
TAKING THE WORD OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN OVER THE ENTIRE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, OUR
NATIONAL REPUTATION AS BEING
TARNISHED.
>> Bret: WE DON'T KNOW IF
JOE BIDEN WILL RUN FOR PRESIDENT
OR NOT BUT HE WAS PRETTY
CRITICAL OF CODDLING DICTATORS.
MOST DEMOCRATS CAME OUT AND SAY,
IT IS GOOD HE WALKED AWAY.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN
AMONG SOME TRUMP CRITICS THAT HE
WAS GOING TO PUT A LOT OF
SANCTIONS ON THE TABLE AND PUT
IT FORMER ANGELI WERE ON THE
TABLE AND NOT GET ANYTHING
CONCRETE AND RETURN.
PARTICULARLY GIVING
NORTH KOREANS MATERIAL.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF RELIEF
ON THE PART OF CRITICS THAT HE
DIDN'T SET US ON A ROAD THAT